[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie we finally have
a date for iron fist so there's gonna be
a breakdown of what's happening with
that in defenders Punisher in the other
Netflix series but they're basically
just teasing the place where iron fist
goes to get his training to get his
powers the thing about this you might
recognize this date this is the date
that daredevil season 2 came out this
past year now obviously there's like a 1
day difference but it's the same weekend
that daredevil season 2 came out so I
think Netflix is gonna try and stick
with this so when they get to daredevil
season 3 next year they'll premiere it
around this time that year now they're
gonna have an interesting thing going on
because they have Jessica Jones season 2
in production right now it seems like
they're actually stealth shooting some
punisher stuff right now - if they're
not finishing defenders because
defenders is supposed to be the next
thing after iron fist it's supposed to
air sometime during the summer of next
year but they haven't officially
confirmed that yet so you have Luke Cage
season 2 you have daredevil season 3
Jessica Jones season 2 you basically
have like the next season of all the
individual character shows so it seems
like they're headed in a Marvel movies
direction where they have so much
content they need to drop three series
during year like Marvel's getting ready
to drop three movies a year instead of
two movies so what you'll probably wind
up seeing is is they'll be like a series
in the spring one in the summer and then
one later in the year like around this
time but any of that could change like
Netflix always looks at the data from
like how people watch stuff year to year
during different times of the year so
they decide that more people tend to
watch these series really late in the
year
then they'll air during November like
Jessica Jones was in November series but
they're supposed to be dropping new Iron
Fist footage at New York Comic Con which
is part of the reason why I think they
didn't drop this right after that 13th
episode of Luke Cage and just to say
like there was actually an iron fist
Easter egg a really big one at the end
of Luke Cage so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen Luke Cage
yet is not super spoilery because you
kind of know that
iron fist is coming next but at the very
end of Luke Cage Claire temple sees an
advertisement for a martial arts school
led by a person named Colleen wing so
immediately you're like oh my god she's
like the misty night of the iron fist TV
show although if you've seen Luke Cage
you know that it's not quite the same
thing misty night of the TV show is
nothing like misty night of the comics
so you can see how they're changing a
few things so like Colleen wing is gonna
be something of a love interest for iron
fist and what I think is gonna happen
when that series starts is that they'll
plot it out in a similar way to Luke
Cage with the way they tell the
backstory like you'll see him you know
with like the full beard like he's just
come back to the city in the first
moments of episode one they kind of did
that with Luke Cage episodes where they
jumped around in time just opening on an
action scene and then flashing back to
what happened that led up to that moment
but I'll say after Luke Cage I am so
ready for iron fist one of my only
complaints I'll do another Luke Cage
video where I review the rest of the
series but it did feel plotless at times
like you weren't sure exactly what it
was building to with each of these
characters like you know the criminals
want to control Harlem but like what do
they want beyond that it's just that
some of the plot was just a little too
general almost as if there was no plot
until diamondback showed up and even
then it kind of fizzled towards the end
it was almost like a non ending so I'm
hoping that's not the case with iron
fist just the pitches is that it's
martial arts with you know full-blown
Chi force so you think that it'd be a
little more action-oriented but if you
don't know anything about iron fist
Danny Rand is a billionaire in the
Marvel Universe his family built a
company called Rand Meechum that's where
all his money comes from but his father
and his mother die while they're on this
trip going to Kuhn loot like his father
is trying to get back to this special
place it seems very much like where the
chaste are from in the daredevil
universe like you have stick who's a
member of the chase The Secret order in
the comics it's a very different thing
but they might make it the same thing on
the TV show remains to be seen but
essentially Danny Rand goes off and
trains in this interdimensional space
learns to harness the force of his Chi
and that becomes his superpower so he
becomes the immortal iron fist but
Madame Gao seems like she's gonna be a
bigger thing during his series so I'm
expecting her to pop up in the actual
kingpin like the actual real villain
like the Diamondback so to speak of his
movie will be David Wenham who's playing
Harold Meacham so they're actually they
cast like a couple Meechum characters
Jerry Hogarth are jeryn hogarth everyone
to think about her from Jessica Jones is
gonna guest star she's the lawyer for
iron fists family remember they're
billionaires she's this high-powered
lawyer so you have Danny ran coming back
from the dead so to speak taking his
fortune back so you can imagine like
this billion-dollar company that his
family is in with the Meacham's become
something of a revenge story because
Meechum is responsible for his father's
death so there's a revenge element to it
the steel serpent becomes kind of like
the dark iron fist eventually so they
might change a few of the characters
from the comics it's just the Meechum
family is a very big thing in iron fist
story so they're gonna be a big thing in
season one but Colleen wing will kind of
be like a Claire temple misty Knight
type character for iron fist but in the
comics we all know iron fist is with
misty Knight they might build to that in
a future season but it seems like misty
knight of the Netflix universe is a
little bit older like Luke Cage is a
little bit older like he's almost in his
40s it seems like so iron fist seems
younger than that so I think there's
gonna be just like a few things that are
different from the comics let me know
what are you excited for I know
Defenders is a big question we're all
like okay are they gonna do Shadowland
because of what they did in daredevil
season two if you haven't caught up on
the Netflix series two now is the time
to do that you have till the spring
before iron fist starts so we should
learn more about what's going on with
the Punisher with defenders in iron fist
all in the next week during New York
Comic Con so whatever ends up happening
I'll do a video for it be sure to
subscribe to get that all also finish my
Luke Cage because there's no agents of
shield episode this week I completely
forgot about that
there's no agents of shield airing it's
on break so I'll do Luke Cage before
arrow tomorrow so gay night is gonna be
awesome in my flash video is going to
post tonight after the episode airs so
be sure to watch it
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for like the last big
clip from episode 1 and you can click
here for that defenders trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight